je suis économiste et
il m'arrive quelque chose incroyable je
tombe enceinte être en famille et avoir
des enfants m'a fait réfléchir sur
beaucoup de choses
et peut-être pour la première fois mais
intérêt personnel et mes intérêts de
recherche se sont mélangés donc avoir un
enfant
ce formidable mais l'enfant s'est imposé
aussi beaucoup des contraintes qu'on
était encore en couple on est libre de
s'organiser comme on voulait si je
voulais visiter mes amis en allemagne et
mon copain ou les faire un week end et
scotch
on a fait ça juste comme ça mais un
enfant il faut s'en occuper
il faut l'amener chez nous il faut le
chercher là bas il faut l'amener à une
visite médicale dans bref on a commencé
de partager une google agenda pour gérer
notre emploi du temps et on a aussi
commencé de négocier et on n'était pas
toujours d'accord
en fait ces négociations en couple sont
différentes des négociations qu'on
observe ailleurs par exemple si on veut
acheter une voiture dans des telles
négociations
normalement chacun pense juste à soi
même donc on veut avoir un produit qui
est plus intéressant ou un prix qui est
un peu plus bas pendant les négociations
couple le problème n'est pas normalement
quand chacun pense juste à soi même mais
qu'on n'est pas d'accord quel sera le
mieux pour le couple
donc on négocie des questions des
principes et ça c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui je voulais vous parler un
peu de ces questions de principe n'ont
en général il existe deux différentes
manières de résoudre de tels problèmes
pour un couple le premier approche et
d'optimiser d'être efficace donc dans un
tel couple on va comparer les
compétences
et la personne qui sait mieux faire
quelque chose par exemple à réparer une
voiture ou faire la cuisine va prendre
en charge cette tâche
le résultat va être une spécialisation
et les compétences vont être de plus en
plus différentes
le même argument peut aussi être utilisé
pour décider qui va travailler ou
combien de temps chacun va travailler
donc dans une couple efficace on va
comparer les salaires et la personne qui
a un salaire plus élevé à se spécialiser
sur le marché de travail et la personne
qui a le salaire plus bas va s'adapter
prendre des postes peut-être un peu
moins intéressant
travailler à mi temps prendra en charge
la ménage et s'occuper des enfants
maintenant dans le plupart de pays les
salaires pour les hommes sont plus
élevés que les salaires pour les femmes
donc vous pouvez un peut deviner qu est
ce que vous arrivez donc ce l'homme qui
va se spécialiser sur le marché de
travail et c'est la femme qui va
s'occuper de la ménage et des enfants
donc ça c'est une approche qui est
efficace mais qui est très inégale au
niveau des contributions aux revenus de
la ménage donc le deuxième approche sera
d'être plutôt égale donc dans un tel
couple l'homme et la femme sont tous les
deux actifs sur le marché de travail et
aussi et se partagent les tâches
ménagères et s'occupe des enfants
une telle couple va être peut-être un
peu moins efficace mais les
contributions de chacun vont être
beaucoup plus paraît donc il ya beaucoup
de bonnes raisons pour chacun des ces
deux approches l'efficacité s'est bien
passé on va avoir plus pour le couple
l'égalité aussi c'est bien pour avoir un
bon équilibre dans le couple la
spécialisation c'est bien parce que
chacun on va être vraiment une externe
dans les tâches qui va prendre en charge
mais on sait aussi bien de savoir on
peut tout faire
donc une question que je m'avait posé en
temps d'économies
myst c'était qu'elle ait la préférence
des hommes et des femmes pour
l'efficacité versus l'égalité dans le
couple donc dans la réalité c'est très
très difficile de mesurer ou d'observer
cette pré ses préférences donc
finalement il faut poser la question en
personne donc ça ce qu'est ce qu'on a
fait on a organisé une expérience pour
laquelle on a invité des couples vivent
ensemble de venir dans notre laboratoire
pour répondre à des questions qui nous
permet de mesurer leur intérêt pour
l'efficacité ou l'égalité donc dans
notre laboratoire on a séparé les hommes
et les femmes
donc chacun a répondu pour soi-même un
comptable à des questions qui concernait
la location d'une ressource entre eux
mêmes et leurs partenaires et c'était
une ressource réel car on a donné à nos
couples en moyenne presque 100 euros
pour la participants participation dans
cette expérience
donc voici une telle situation qu'on a
proposé à nos participants
il ya deux options l'option à l'option b
l'option à à gauche et une situation qui
est égal parce qu'on va donner à l'homme
et à la femme de son front toulouzan ça
c'est notre monnaie locale qu'on échange
en euros à la fin de l'expérience
l'option b à droite c'est une situation
qui est efficace
on va donner 450 francs toulouzan au
couple mais le tout va être donné à
l'homme un rien à la fin donc chacun de
nos participants a dû faire une choix
entre cette option à et cette option b
en sachant qu'à la fin de l'expérience
chaque participant va recevoir un
enveloppe avec ses gains inviduelles de
cette expérience
donc on a observé que presque 40 % des
participants ont choisi la situation qui
est égal et le résultat était le même
pour les hommes et les femmes en ça veut
dire 40 % des femmes ont choisi cette
option est aussi
40% des hommes ont choisi cette option
donc tous les hommes ça peut sembler un
peu étonnant ici parce que si vous
regardez les deux options ont fait
l'homme mort à 450 francs toulousain
dans l'option b donc ça c'est beaucoup
plus et en plus il est libre de partager
cette somme
après l'expérience avec sa femme
d'accord mais ça semble quand même un
grand pourcentage des personnes à un
intérêt pour l'égalité même si c'est
coûteux et les coups ici il n'est pas
négligeable donc pour voir le coup il
faut comparer le total dans les deux
options il a une différence de 50 francs
donc ça veut dire il y a un coût de plus
que 10% associés à cette égalité donc
pourquoi existe il tel intérêt pour
l'égalité même si c'est coûteux donc ici
il ya deux points de vue
premièrement on à la personne qui est
des défavorisés c'est facile de voir
pourquoi une personne qui est
défavorisée va avoir une préférence pour
l'égalité va avoir plus être moins
dépendante se sentir moins coupable
c'est un peu plus difficile de voir
pourquoi aussi une personne qui est
favori c'est peut aussi avoir un intérêt
pour l'égalité mais c'est pas toujours
facile d'avoir plus on peut pas juste
sonné l'argent comme cadeau à quelqu'un
d'autre
il va se sentir en dép t il va assister
de nous réveiller
si vous inviter quelqu'un dans une
restaurant il va insister de payer la
prochaine fois en plus si vous êtes dans
une situation favorisée et vous savez
que votre partenaire est malheureux
c'est très probable que vous êtes prêt
de payer une certaine prix pour donner
une situation mieux aussi à votre
partenaire
on a aussi proposé une situation inverse
dans une situation où on a donné le tout
à la femme est rien à l'homme
et le résultat est le même d'accord donc
même aussi dans cette situation là les
hommes et des femmes ils ont les mêmes
préférences plus ou moins 40 %
choisissent cette option qui égalitaire
on observe un peu le même résultat si on
regarde le marché du travail dont 10000
2011 en france on avait dans 44 % des
ménages
l'homme et la femme qui travaillait à
plein temps donc ce que notre résultat
montre ce que ceci n'est pas juste une
résultat parce qu'on va avoir plus
d'argent c'est en a deux salaires en
place d'une mais qu'il ya un vrai
intérêt pour l'égalité et que les
couples sont même près de payer un
certain prix pour avoir l'égalité mais
on a aussi vu que les couples sont assez
rationnel par rapport par rapport à
cette prime à sept coups par exemple on
a proposé une situation où on a augmenté
le coût ici en amenant donné 600 francs
alors dans la situation qui est efficace
dans le maintenant la différence 200
francs toulouse ça ça veut dire il ya un
coût de 33 %
associé à l'égalité et dans 7 cas on a
vu que justin % des participants ont
choisi la situation égale ça veut dire
il existe un vrai intérêt pour l'égalité
par les couples mais finalement tout
dépend du prix donc si le prix commence
être trop élevées à un moment on dit bon
ça coûte trop cher et maintenant c'est
aussi important de réfléchir un peu
qu'est ce que c'est cette course prix
dans la réalité
ici j'ai beaucoup simplifié j'ai juste
parlé des salaires mais un coût qui est
très très important dans la situation
qui toujours genre c'est la pression
sociale
donc si en plus dans une société tout le
monde pense qu'une homme doit gagner
plus que la femme
ça ajoute encore un autre coup à notre
couple
on a aussi vu qu' il ya une prendre
variance dans les préférences donc
certaines personnes sont près de payer
une prix plus élevés que d autres c'est
une question de personnalité des
préférences individuelles
on a aussi vu que la culture jouait un
rôle assez importante donc par exemple
l'honneur
effet cette expérience en allemagne et
on a vu que pour exactement les mêmes
sortes situation parmi les couples
allemand une plus grand pourcentage à
chaud si la situation égale dont il faut
en parler ni l'une ni l'autre approche
est nécessairement mieux mais il faut
être d'accord
quelle approche on veut suivre on a
aussi vu dans notre expérience que dans
25 à 30 % des couples
l'homme et la femme n'ont pas choisi la
même option
c'est tout à fait normal qu'on n'a pas
les mêmes préférences dans une couple
d'autres
parlons-en souvent c'est difficile de
parler de l'argent dans le couple on ne
fait jamais ou juste quand c'est trop
tard mais c'est important aussi souvent
nous pensons que les autres ont les
mêmes références que nous mêmes car ça
semble tellement évident de notre point
de vue mais si ce n'est pas vrai donc
pour savoir quelle est l'importance de
l'égalité pour où et si vous êtes prêt
de payer un prix pour la voix il faut en
discuter
[Applaudissements]